PROFESSOR: Today, we are going
to change gears after the
first hour to a very different
set of topics.
What I wanted to do today was to
take a look at notation for
space groups.
And this is a question that
is far from trivial.
There are conventions, and we'll
see the reasons for them
with a few examples.
And then I would like to pass
around representations of some
non-trivial space groups.
First, as they appear in the old
International Tables for
X-Ray Crystallography,
Volume 1.
And then second, to give you a
look at the larger, heavier,
and much more expensive Volume
A, which gives much more
information which is both its
liability and its advantage.
There are things in there
that are not in the
international tables.
But there's so much information
and so cluttered
that it's really overwhelming.
But I'll give you a chance of
what their representations of
the space group look like.
Let me begin by passing around
an example of the information
in the International Tables,
Volume 1 for one of the
orthorhombic space groups.
And it all fits on one page.
It's not terribly complicated.
But it is considerably more
complex both in the
arrangement of atoms and in
the cluster of symmetry
elements, compared to the very
simple monoclinic space groups
which we looked at in their
entirety and in
considerable detail.
So first of all, some indication
of what's on the
lower part of the page.
This is exactly analogous
to what you've seen and
presumably are familiar
with for the two
dimensional plane groups.
There are many possible origins
that could be selected
for the 0, 0, 0, position
relative to which the atomic
locations are expressed.
So the first thing, just below
the picture of the arrangement
of atoms and the depiction of
the arrangement of symmetry
elements is a statement of
where the origin is.
So it says, origin at the
inversion center 2/m.
And if you look at the
arrangement of symmetry
elements, there is nothing but
the representation for screw
axes normal to the page.
But there is, off on the
right-hand side, a solid
chevron, and that is the
indication for a mirror plane.
Something again that is nowhere
stated, but always
assumed is that the two
variables x and y or the axes
a and b are assumed to run from
upper left to lower left
for a and the coordinate x and
from upper left to upper right
for the axis b.
And therefore, plus c comes out
normal to the plane of the
projection.
Here, for the first time, we're
seeing a complex space
group that really requires the
full range of symbols for
representing the atomic
locations.
You will see, for each circle,
a vertical line
dividing it in half.
These are two atoms then that
are superposed in projection.
One of them, corresponding to
the little comma inside the
circle, is the enantiomorph
of those circles which are
unadorned with that
little comma.
And they are, therefore,
of opposite handedness.
Alongside of each circle, you
will see two symbols giving
the elevation of that atom
within the cell.
The one at the furthest upper
left corner says 1/2 plus.
So this says that the coordinate
is z, whatever that
is for the representative
atom, plus 1/2.
The half of the circle that
has the comma inside has a
minus sign next do it.
That means that it is at
an elevation minus z.
Well, where is the
representative atom?
This is tucked just inside the
corner of the cell where the
vertical line divides
the circle into 1/2.
That is a plus, so that's
an atom at plus z.
The right-hand side of that
circle has a comma.
It's an enantiomorphic motif,
and that exist at 1/2 minus z.
So you find labels on all of
the atoms in the cell.
There are a total of four
clusters of eight.
So are a total of 16 atoms
within the unit cell.
If you look at this pattern
and reflect on it for a
moment, so to speak, you can see
that the same cluster of
eight sits at the corners
of the cell as in the
middle of the cell.
Exactly the same.
So therefore, this is a lattice
that is side-centered.
There's a lattice point at the
corner of the cell and one
lattice point, in addition,
at 1/2, 1/2, 0, in the
center of the cell.
The c-axis comes out of the
plane of the paper.
This then is a side-centered
c-lattice.
And that is the capital letter
symbol that appears first in
the symbol for the
space group.
It is a side-centered lattice,
and the extra lattice point is
in the middle of the face
out of which c comes.
Then come, in the space group
symbol at upper left-- this is
the abbreviated form--
mcm.
And what I wanted to go over
this example specifically for,
there are three directions in
an orthorhombic symmetry, no
one any more or less special
than any other.
So if you look at the
arrangement of symmetry
elements, there's a 2 sub 1
screw axis coming out in the
direction of c.
The symbols running left to
right, arrows and barbs, the
arrows stand for
two-fold axes.
The barbs stand for 2
sub 1 screw axes.
And running up and down parallel
to the a-axis, again,
arrows that indicate two-fold
axes and barbs that indicate 2
sub 1 screw axes.
So which is the special
direction?
Which one should come first?
It's not like a cubic symmetry,
where the direction
of the four-fold axis is always
along the edge of the
unit cell, or a tetragonal
symmetry, where the four-fold
axis is always taken to
be the direction of c.
Here, that's not specified.
So again, the first convention
is that the magnitudes of the
translations determine a, b,
and c in orthorhombic.
Because there's nothing more
or less special about the
symmetry of these three
orthogonal directions.
And the convention which we've
mentioned earlier is that the
magnitude of b is greater
than the magnitude of a.
And then seemingly logically,
c is the smallest.
So if this is the direction of a
and this is the direction of
b, then c comes up.
And this is the intermediate
length translation.
This is the maximum
translation.
And normal to the blackboard is
the shortest translation.
What symmetry goes first?
And here again, for
orthorhombic, we need a
convention.
And the space group
symbol has--
I [INAUDIBLE]
I use lambda for this, but-- a
symbol for the lattice type.
And we've seen that the capital
C that comes first
indicates that there is
a c-centered lattice.
And then what one does for
orthorhombic is give the
symmetry elements in
the order abc.
So the axis that is parallel
to a over the plane that is
perpendicular to a.
Next, the axis that's parallel
to b over the plane that is
perpendicular to b.
And then the axis that is
parallel to c over the plane,
if any, that is perpendicular
to c.
So then this is a convention
for orthorhombic.
And again, this is the only
crystal system where
conventions this elaborate
are necessary.
If this were tetragonal, 4 or
4/m would always come first
because that's the
direction of c.
So even the order of the
symmetry elements is different.
But we've got another problem.
If we look at the axes, if any,
that are along a, we've
got this symbol that stands for
a two-fold axis and this
single barbed arrow that stands
for a 2 sub 1 screw.
So what kind of axis
is along a?
There are two different
kinds of axes.
So in here, we could put either
a 2 or a 2 sub 1.
And if we look at the planes
that are perpendicular to a,
there's two of them.
There's a dashed line, and
this is a glide where the
direction of tau is in the plane
of the paper so that
we're looking edge on in
the glide plane and
perpendicular to tau.
And then there is
a solid line.
That's the symbol for
a mirror plane.
This would be a glide in
which tau is a long b,
so this is a b-glide.
So those are the two sorts of
symmetry planes that are
perpendicular to a.
Again, there are two of them.
So we could put in either m, or
we could put in a for the
plane that is perpendicular
to a.
So already, there are four
different possibilities for
the first character.
So obviously, what I'm leading
up to is the fact that we're
going to have to have
conventions of necessity to
come to a symbol on which
everyone agrees.
I think you get the idea now,
so let me move along quickly
along the direction of the arrow
for a two-fold axis, a
barb for 2 sub 1 screw axis.
So again, there are two kinds of
symmetry axes that could go
in here for the axes that
are parallel to b,
either 2 or 2 sub 1.
If we look at the planes that
are perpendicular to b,
there's a dotted line.
And this is a glide for which
tau is directed upwards.
We're looking directly along
the orientation of tau.
The axis that is normal to
the board is the c-axis.
So this is a c-glide.
And then appears a dash-dot
line alongside of it.
The dash-dot line is a glide
plane where you're looking
neither perpendicular to tau
nor parallel to tau, but
halfway in between.
So this is a glide plane where
tau is equal to 1/2 of
a plus 1/2 of b.
And that's a diagonal glide
represented, just to confuse
the innocent, by the symbol n.
So two choices for
axes along b.
Two choices for the glide
plane, either c or n.
And finally, mercifully, along
the direction of the c-axis,
which is easiest to visualize,
because things are either
along it or parallel to
it, we've got only a
2 sub 1 screw axis.
So this is the only symbol
which is not ambiguous.
And then perpendicular to that,
we have the symbol for a
mirror plane, the solid chevron
off to one side.
And then the chevron adorned
with a diagonal arrow and that
is, again, a diagonal glide n.
We notice that the center of the
cell at z equals 0 is the
same as the grouping of
atoms at the corner.
So that is a side-centered
lattice.
The centered lattice point is
coming out of the face which c
emerges from.
And so this is a c-lattice.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Professor, for the
first term [? x of the ?]
plane perpendicular to a,
why is it a and not b?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
You're absolutely right.
I wrote it down as a b-glide.
Perpendicular to
a is a b-glide.
Good.
Congratulations.
So we need a convention.
And the convention for
establishing a hierarchy of
symbols is easy to remember.
It's if you have both a two-fold
screw axis and a
two-fold axis, the order of
preference is that the 2 is
chosen in preference to the
2 sub 1 screw symbol.
So by this greater than, I
mean the preference for
choosing it is greater than
the symbol to the right.
So we get rid of the
2 sub 1 here.
We pick the 2.
Get rid of the 2 sub 1 here,
and that stays at 2 sub 1.
For planes, you pick m in
preference to an a-glide, in
preference to a b-glide, in
preference to a c-glide, in
preference to a diagonal glide,
in preference to a
diamond glide, assuming
you have a choice of
two different planes.
So in this case, we picked
the m in preference to b.
Here, we've got a c-glide
and an n-glide.
We picked the c, and it's
in preference to the n.
And here again, for the plane
that is perpendicular to c, we
picked the m in preference
to the n.
So the full symbol would be
C, 2 over m, 2 over c, and
2 sub 1 over m.
Now I'll peek and see
if I got this right.
Yes, I did.
How about that?
And the short symbol would be
simply Cmcm, which indeed is
what we see listed in
the upper left-hand
corner of the page.
This is a space group based on
the point group 2/m, 2/m, 2/m,
which is D2h.
And there is the large number
17 in the superscript, which
is the 17th orthorhombic space
group, which Schoenflies was
able to derive in the order
in which he did them.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If you look at the
other symbols to describe the
space group, would we construct
the same space group
using that function
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, you could.
And let me say, yes,
it's possible.
But also to answer a question,
you might have about the short
form of the symbol, we're
throwing away information.
We've thrown away the fact that
there are two-fold axes,
and a pair of directions,
and 2 sub 1 only
in the third direction.
Is it possible that two space
groups could have exactly the
same three symbols in
the short form?
And the answer is no.
Because if you think about it,
you start with a lattice type.
If you put a mirror plane in
one orientation, a mirror
plane in the other orientation,
that really is
all you have to specify in order
to determine every other
symmetry element
that's present.
You simply combine those
operations, and you find that
when you've taken these
symmetries and rotations and
combine them with the lattice
translation, it comes out to
one and the same
unique result.
So your question was what
happens if you take another
three symbols.
You end up with the
same result.
Three of them, really, are
enough to specify what the
group will turn out to be.
Now the other thing I wanted
to do was to show you how
remarkably the symbol for the
space group will change if you
take a different set of axes
simply because the relative
lengths of the cell edge for
this arrangement of symmetry
elements have changed.
This takes dominance.
This determines the labels
that go to the axes.
And then the symbol for the
plane group, and what is a
b-glide, and what is a
c-glide follows from
this choice of axes.
So let me take another
example.
And I think if you follow what
I've done so far, I can zip
through this a little
more quickly.
Somebody pick a new direction
for this axis.
Let's not pick a.
We have used that for this.
So somebody pick a b or a c.
Do you want to pick
a b or a c?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: b.
So we're going to change
this direction to b.
Somebody want to pick a
label for this axis?
AUDIENCE: c.
PROFESSOR: c.
And nobody gets to
pick this axis.
If you think you can,
you're out of here.
Because that now has determined
the coordinate system.
So we've got b this
way, c this way.
We want a right-handed
abc convention.
So a goes up.
So abc right-handed system.
So exactly the same arrangement
of symmetry
elements except that we've
now changed the
labels on the axes.
So we have changed the name that
we have to apply to the
glide planes.
So let me now proceed to write
down here the new collection
of symbols which would appear
for this setting of exactly
the same space group.
First of all, the centered
lattice point is now in the
middle of the face out
of which a comes.
So this is an a-lattice,
side-centered a.
If we look along the direction
of a, all that we have for an
axis is 2 sub 1.
Then we have these two planes.
One is an m.
One is a diagonal glide.
So that is m or n.
If I look along b, I have the
choice of either 2 or 2 sub 1
as both are present.
Perpendicular to b, however,
is a glide for which tau is
along the direction of c.
So that is a c-glide.
And then the other symbol for
an axis that's perpendicular
to b is a mirror plane.
So it's either c or m.
Then finally, along the
direction of c, I once more
have two-fold axes and
2 sub 1 screw axes.
And then perpendicular to
c is a diagonal glide.
And this is a glide.
The dotted line indicates
that the direction of
tau is along a.
So I have a choice of either
a or n in here.
So putting down the symbols in
the order of preference, this
would be A, 2 sub 1 over
m, 2 over m, 2 over a.
Or the short form of the symbol
would be Amma, which I
submit doesn't look anything
like Cmcm.
And when you start out in
diffraction, many people have
a first disconcerting
experience.
You spend probably the better
part of a month taking single
crystal diffraction patterns.
You come up with a trial
space group for
your particular material.
And then you go to the
International Tables, and you
say, oh, it's not in there,
what did I do wrong?
And you go back, and you check
all your calculations.
You look once more at all of
the systematic absence of
reflection.
See, I have it right.
Why is it not in there?
Well, the answer is more than
likely that you have a
different setting for
the labels that you
applied to the axes.
And you have, therefore,
metamorphosed the symbol for
the space group from one
form to a symbol that
is very, very different.
How do you tell, when you have a
particular space group, what
all of the possible symbols
for one and the same
symmetry might be?
So let me now pass
out two things.
If you have a question like
that, you can bet your bottom
bippy that it's in the
International Tables if you
look in the right place.
So first of all, let me
do something I should
have done early on.
I meant to hand out a copy
of the space group
that I drew up here.
If I can find it again.
It's buried with all of the
stuff that I brought in.
So I do have a copy for you, but
it's gone at the moment.
Let me pass out a listing of all
of the possible variants
of the space groups for the 230
three-dimensional space groups.
And it starts out simple for
triclinic symmetries.
There's only two possible
symbols period, P1 and P1 bar.
And then when you come to
monoclinic, the Schoenflies
symbol has the marvelous
property that it is
independent of the orientation
and labelling of axes.
It depends only on the point
group that the crystal has.
For monoclinic, either
C2 or Cs--
that's a mirror plane--
or C2h--
that's 2 over a horizontal
mirror plane.
But the labels can still change
depending whether in
the first setting either a, b,
or the diagonal of the oblique
net has to be labeled a and c.
So at the top of the column,
you'll see the permutation of
the two symbols a and
b or b and a.
And again, the change
is significant.
Number eight, as indicated
in the left-hand column,
can be Am or Bm.
And for the groups that are
based on 2 over m, you can
see, again, there are
different symbols.
A, 2 over b, A, 2 over a.
Again, not at all similar.
Next, come the orthorhombic
space groups.
And you can amuse yourself
by looking through those.
Again, what is called the
standard setting under the
heading symbols for various
settings, this is the one
that's listed in the tables.
But then for various
permutations of a, b, and c,
you can have five other
possibilities.
And you can marvel at how the
symbol for the space group
changes, as you do nothing but
change the labels a, b, and c
that goes onto the axes.
So there are tons of
orthorhombic space groups
because you have three different
axes to play with,
and three different
planes, and four
different lattice types.
So there is an absolutely mind
boggling collection of
orthorhombic space groups.
It is the most densely populated
crystal system.
For tetragonal, no
real alternative.
Something like P4, 4 is in the
direction of the c-axis.
There are two-fold axes parallel
to that, but the
symbol that is used for the
symmetry part of the space
group symbol looks very, very
much like the symbol for the
point group.
So these are pretty much
self-explanatory.
Notice that there are two
kinds of lattices for
tetragonal crystals, either
primitive or body-centered.
So you see families with P
for primitive or I for
body-centered.
But notice how many you can get
out of a single type of
axis and a single lattice.
Numbers 75, 76, 77, and 78 are
a four-fold axis and a
primitive lattice, a 4 sub 1
screw, a 4 sub 2 screw, or a 4
sub 3 screw.
Then you do the same thing
with I. And so it goes.
Then it picks up at the
top of the page again.
And you see, again, different
possibilities for the symbols.
Continuing still on-- and I
think you have the idea now--
same for trigonal crystals.
They chose to list those
separate from hexagonal.
And then hexagonal symmetries.
The number is fairly large here
because when you take an
axis and add it to a primitive
hexagonal lattice--
for number 168, for example--
you get P6.
Change the six-fold axis
to a screw axis.
There are five different types
of six-fold screw axes.
So there's a P6 sub 1, a P6 sub
2, a P6 sub 3, a P6 sub 4,
and a P6 sub 5.
And then finally, cubic.
A fair number of cubic
symmetries.
But the edge of the cell is
always along the direction of
the four-fold axis or the
two-fold axis, depending on
whether the symmetry is based
on 2, 3 or 4, 3, 2.
So there are really no
alternative symbols for
different settings of the
symmetry elements
relative to the edges.
So there you have them.
All 230 of our cast
of characters.
But in forms of the very
different mantles in which
they can be cloaked.
What else did I want to do?
I want to contrast what is done
for us in the old Volume
1 of the International Tables.
And I will pass out an example
for one of the tetragonal
space groups.
This is the one with maximum
symmetry 4 over m, 2
over m, 2 over m.
Sorry.
Can you pass those back?
And this is something that is
analogous to P4mm in two
dimensions with the four-fold
and two-fold axes extended
parallel to the edge of what
is now a tetragonal cell.
And then there are two-fold
axes perpendicular to the
four-fold axis.
So actually 4 over m, 2 over m,
2 over m has been dropped
in at a lattice point of a
primitive tetragonal lattice.
The chevron in the upper right
of the arrangement of symmetry
elements is the mirror plane
that's perpendicular to the
four-fold axis.
The other mirror planes
are the same as in
the plane group P4mm.
And the glide plane, which now
would be called a diagonal
glide, is exactly the
same as in the
two-dimensional symmetry.
Notice, however, the exquisite
number of general and special
positions that are present
in the space group.
The general position has the
letter U. You've gone through
almost the entire alphabet
before you've labeled all of
these positions.
And again, either on the mirror
planes, but now there's
a vertical mirror plane, a
diagonal vertical mirror
plane, a horizontal mirror
plane, mirror planes halfway
along each of the axes, mirror
planes halfway along the
diagonal translation.
So there are lots of positions
of point group m.
Lots of positions with
point group 2mm.
And then finally, 2 over
m, 2 over m, 2 over m.
And the highest symmetry, 4 over
m, 2 over m, 2 over m,
which occurs at the origin, at
the center of the cell, and at
the positions 0, 0, 1/2
and 1/2, 1/2, 1/2.
Then I'd like to pass around
one more example of a space
group from the International
Tables.
And I know I copied it, and
I don't have it with me.
I left some stuff behind,
which we'll get
after we take our break.
No, here it is.
This is an example from Volume
1, the older edition, for one
of the cubic point groups.
And this is a very
high symmetry.
This is symmetry 4 over m, 3
bar 2 over m, the highest
symmetry cubic point group
dropped into a
body-centered lattice.
So this turns out to be, in the
long form, I, 4 over m, 3
bar, 2 over m.
Let me pass these back.
So the first thing you'll
notice is no picture of
symmetry elements.
How do you draw something where
the symmetry elements
are not merely parallel to the
plane of the depiction or
perpendicular to it?
Here, you've got mirror planes
that are inclined to the
paper, axes that are inclined
to the paper.
How do you represent them?
You'll notice also the enormous
number of atoms in
the general position.
96 atoms.
Drop in one atom at xyz, and
all hell breaks loose.
You get 95 other atoms.
And again, when the lattice is
centered, they do not list all
96 sets of coordinates.
They denote at the top of the
page 0, 0, 0, 1/2, 1/2, plus.
That means because the lattice
is body-centered to those 48
positions that are listed, you
add 0, 0, 0, which is easy to
do, and then add 1/2, 1/2,
1/2 to x, y, and z.
And these are the atoms
that hang at the
centered lattice point.
Again, because the symmetry is
so high, surprisingly, there
are not that many special
positions.
Because all of the symmetry
elements can serve as special
positions are related by the
symmetry that's there.
So this is all that you see for
the body-centered lattice
with 4 over m, 3 bar, 2 over
m dropped into it.
And again, you can describe some
very, very complicated
crystal structures with a very
brief set of notes, give the
value of the single lattice
constant a.
And then say, you've got an atom
in the general position
96l with x equals something, y
equals something, z equals
some number.
And another atom in position
16f x, x, x, and just the
value of x would be given.
So you've described a structure
that has roughly 125
atoms in it with just
that modest
specification of atomic positions.
Let me now pass out for you some
samples of what the space
groups look like in Volume A
of the new International
Tables for Crystallography.
Not X-ray crystallography,
but just
crystallography in general.
And I think you will be blown
away because the amount of
information that's there is
almost suffocating in its
detail and its density.
The first sample space group
that is given here is, not by
coincidence, one of the
tetragonal space groups, the
one that we just discussed, P,
4 over m, 2 over m, 2 over m.
They've done some very
useful things.
They have specified the
asymmetric unit within which
you need specify coordinates
of atoms.
And here, they say that you
have to tell what's in the
range x equals 0 to x equal 1/2,
y equals 0 to y equals
1/2, and z equal to 1/2, but
greater or equal to 0.
Then they give a representative
set of symmetry
operations which generate
all of the atoms
within the unit cell.
The symmetry operations are not
independent, but they list
16 symmetry elements.
And now if you look to the next
page on the list of 16
atomic coordinates in the
general position, you will see
a number in parentheses
in front of each one.
The 15, for example, tells you
that you get this atom from
the atom at xyz by the operation
of symmetry element
15, which turns out to be a
mirror plane parallel to the x
minus xz direction.
And this is very, very useful
if you want to describe a
structure and you've labeled
your atoms silicon 1 and
silicon 2 if they're two
different kinds of silicon ion
in the structure.
And then you're talking about
a silicon, oxygen, silicon
bond, and it's not at all clear
which of the symmetry
related atoms are involved
in that bond.
Well, the presentation of a
standard numbering of atoms
related by symmetry lets you say
that, for example, this is
the bond between silicon
superscript 5, oxygen, silicon
superscript 14.
And you can identify the
coordinates of the atoms that
went into that particular bond
angle or bond distance.
And that's very nice.
All sorts of information
a la group theory.
The maximal non-isomorphic
subgroups, the maximal
isomorphic subgroups of lowest
index, the minimal
non-isomorphic supergroups.
At one time, I may have known
what all that meant, and I've
long since forgotten
and have never
regretted having forgotten.
So this is very exotic,
higher-level information about
the subgroups that exist
for the space group.
Notice how much more information
is present though,
compared to the depiction of
the same space group in the
earlier International Tables
for X-Ray Crystallography.
Well, more or less at
random, I picked out
some other space groups.
I, 4 sub 1, amd.
So this is 4 over m, 2 over m,
2 over m in which the 4 has
been replaced by a 4
sub 1 screw axis.
The mirror plane perpendicular
to the edge of the cell
replaced b an a-glide.
The mirror plane for the
second mirrors that's
perpendicular to the cell edge,
the a-glide is diagonal.
And then perpendicular
to the diagonal,
two-fold axis is a d-glide.
Again, the different operations
are identified by a
number, the glide plane, and
the inversion centers, and
two-fold axes that
are present.
And then in the coordinates of
the general position, you are
given the nature of the symmetry
element that produces
the atom at a particular set of
coordinates from the atom
that's in the general
position.
Now again, the maximal
non-isomorphic this, the
minimal non-isomorphic
supergroup, and so on.
Lots of information.
Then some examples of still
higher symmetries.
P6 sub 3 over mmc based on 6
over m, 2 over m, 2 over m
with the 6 replaced by a 6 sub
3 screw axis and one of the
mirror planes replaced
by a c-glide.
If you go on, here comes the
really exciting part.
The next page gives
you a depiction of
a cubic space group.
Heroic.
What they do is show
stereographic projections at
locations, such as 0, 0, 0 and
0, 1/2, 1/2, I believe it is.
And then the best part of all,
down at the bottom of that
page, you see the arrangement
of atoms in stereo.
And if you're one of these
people who can stare at the
thing cross-eyed and let your
eyes sort of blonk out, you
can watch the two
halves merge.
And all of a sudden, zing, the
thing leaps out of the page at
you in three dimensions.
If you don't have that ability
to cross your eyes and see
stereographic projections, you
have to get a little viewer.
But nevertheless, if you want to
see it in three dimensions
badly enough, you can do it.
So there you are.
For the first time, pictures
of the general position in
cubic space groups.
I think that's kind of fun.
Sometimes I gaze at it for so
long I'm afraid my eyes are
going to get stuck.
And then I'll be in
real trouble.
Here's another one.
P 4 over m, 3 bar, 2 over m.
You notice the problems that
they have in indicating the
orientation of three-fold axes
which are not parallel to or
perpendicular to the paper.
You have to do that with
a little stereographic
projection.
And then finally, after we've
done a couple of more cubic
space groups, you come to the
one that I gave you the
handout from the International
Tables for X-Ray
Crystallography.
I, 4 over m, 3 bar, 2 over m.
And look at all the information
that is there that
no attempt is made to give you
in the earlier tables.
So this is for better or
for worse what space
group tables look like.
This is the information
that hopefully you'll
be equipped to use.
If nothing else, if you can't
derive these things or
reproduce the arrangement of
symmetries from the symbol, if
you ever have to construct the
atomic arrangement from a
material from the
crystallographic notation in
which the atomic arrangement is
provided, you can hopefully
go to the International Tables,
know where to look,
and how to go about identifying
the coordinates of
all of the atoms within
the unit cell.
Timed myself to finish just
at five of the hour.
So let me, before you leave,
give you one final problem set
on symmetry, problem
set number 10.
And this is related to
identifying what the symbols
used to give atomic locations
represent.
First problem asks you to look
at a pair of atoms and
determine the symmetry element
which has related them.
The second problem on the second
sheet asks you to do
what we did here for this
orthorhombic space group.
Determine the symbol when a,
b, and c are particular
translations of the three
that are unique.
And then change the orientation,
and see what the
space group symbol
morphs into.
Let me finish with one
final handout.
And that is could you please
summarize what we spent the
last month and a half doing?
Gladly.
I have summarized everything
that we did and the theorems
that we used to derive it
on one piece of paper.
So all of symmetry theory is
here admittedly written in a
rather tight hand.
But here is an indication of
everything we did to get from
a definition of basic
operations, a flowsheet that
gets us down to 230
three-dimensional
crystallographic space groups.
So I'll pass that around for
your awe and amazement.
Sorry I gave a big
pack out on the
right-hand side of the room.
They'll come around to you.
So let us take our usual
10 minute break.